horror icons prime time stars criminals
and queens the cast of the craft has
done it all want to know which breakout
performer captured ben stiller's heart
wondering why you recognized the pilot
from sharknado keep watching to learn
all about this ensemble cast
sarah bailey played by robin tunney is a
bit unsure of herself and not just
because she recently transferred to a
new school she doesn't know how or why
she's able to do the things she can and
fears she'll lose control of her powers
and hurt the people around her following
the craft tony got another dose of the
supernatural in 1999's iconically bad
end of days she plays the role of
christine york a woman whom the devil
played by gabriel byrne has selected to
be the mother of the antichrist unless
arnold schwarzenegger has anything to
say about it
christie
come to me
i am the one you've been waiting for
i am the answer to your prayers for
2000's critically panned vertical limit
tony took on the role of annie garrett a
trapped mountain climber in need of
rescue by her brother played by chris
o'donnell
tunney later appeared in 2006's period
crime drama hollywoodland which told a
fictionalized version of the death of
superman actor george reeves portrayed
by ben affleck she plays lenore lemon
reeve's fiancee at the time of his death
in 2008 tony took up the role of teresa
lisbon boss and love interest to the
title character on usa's procedural
drama the mentalist more recently she
had a lead role as maya travis on abc's
ill-fated legal drama the fix
faruza bach plays the ambitious and
spiteful role of nancy downes
unsatisfied by the insurance payout from
her late stepfather's death and jealous
of sarah's natural talent nancy goes to
drastic measures to strengthen her
powers and outclass her friends the same
year the craft hit theaters bach washed
off the goth makeup and popped in some
custom incisors for the role of human
cat hybrid aisa in the remake of the
island of dr moreau
two years later bach brought to life
another complicated hungry young woman
for 1998's american history x she played
stacy the soon-to-be ex-girlfriend of
recently former neo-nazi skinhead derek
vineyard played by edward norton the
very same year she took on the decidedly
lighter role of vicki valencourt love
interest to adam sandler's character
bobby boucher in the sports comedy the
waterboy in 2015 bach landed a recurring
role on the showtime drama ray donovan
playing ginger a prostitute who
befriends the title character's father
in amazon's series paradise city bach
plays the role of lizzie thomas the
grandmother to faith the daughter to
series lead johnny faust played by andy
biersack
bonnie harper as played by actor nev
campbell starts out on the quiet side
covered in mysterious burn scars she
does her best to hide as much of her
body as possible when sarah shows up and
the witches have their fourth she
manages to remove her scars completely
and gains newfound confidence in her
appearance from then on the craft really
put campbell on the path to being a 90s
it girl the same year the craft came out
she starred as protagonist sydney
prescott in wes craven's teen horror
flick scream
campbell went on to reprise the role for
the 1997 sequel scream 2 as well as
2000's scream 3 and 2011's scream 4.
following craven's death in 2015
campbell also appeared in scream 5 which
came out in january of 2022 in addition
to the teen horror film genre campbell
has also found success on the small
screen in the popular drama party of
five she stars as orphan julia salinger
she also enjoyed a recurring role as
political strategist leanne harvey on
netflix's political thriller drama house
of cards
rochelle zimmerman played by rachel true
rounds out the quartet of young witches
in addition to dabbling in witchcraft
she is also a member of the school's
diving team despite her diving talent
she's bullied relentlessly by her
teammate laura lara's racist taunts lead
rochelle to seek revenge eventually
causing the superficial pretty girl to
lose her hair and become despondent two
years after filming the craft true
joined the cast of half-baked
in the dim stoner comedy she played the
super cleverly named mary jane potman
opposite dave chappelle's character
thurgood jenkins mary jane is their
goods love interest in the film
eventually forcing him to choose between
sex or smoking weed marijuana is
terrible
it's a gateway drug and everybody knows
that it leads to other stuff
beginning in 2002 true took on the role
of mona thorne in the upn sitcom half
and half which followed the unexpected
friendship between mona and her
half-sister didi played by essence
atkins
true appeared on the show throughout its
entire four season run before it was
cancelled in 2006. more recently true
appeared as johnny valentine in
sharknado 2 the second one troop plays
the first officer aboard flight 209 a
plane attacked by airborne sharks
unfortunately she doesn't last long
that same year she appeared in blood
lake attack of the killer lampreys as
marcy a member of the fish and wildlife
service who falls prey to the title
monsters
actor skeet ulrich took on the role of
repugnant chris hooker like many
archetypal campus kings chris maintains
a good guy persona when the occasion
calls for it feigning innocence and
sidestepping the truth like an
all-american running back when chris
doesn't get what he wants the charm
turns off and the mean-spirited bully
comes out sarah manages to tame him with
a love spell but this eventually
backfires when chris becomes obsessed
and dangerous
ulric had a prolific run in the mid 90s
with the craft serving as one of his
five film appearances in 1996 alone
later that year he joined co-star nev
campbell in the franchise launching
scream though his character didn't enjoy
the same longevity as hers ulrich played
billy loomis sidney prescott's boyfriend
and initial murder suspect after
revealing himself as one of the two
killers alongside his friend and
co-conspirator stew played by matthew
lillard sydney shoots him in the head
the actor went on to appear as vincent
the model turned assailant in 1997's
acclaimed as good as it gets two decades
later ulrich took up the role of forsyth
pendleton jones ii on cw's riverdale
ulrich played the reformed criminal
father to jughead and eventual riverdale
sheriff for five seasons before
departing the series in an interview
with variety ulrich stated i'm leaving
riverdale because i got bored creatively
mitt chris's slacker best friend is
brought to life by actor brecken meyer
mitt is goofy but a loyal friend to
chris he's seemingly got nothing but
wisecracks to offer until he gets an
eyeful of scar-free bonnie that is in
1998 meyer appeared in 54 alongside
fellow 90s up-and-comer ryan phillippe
with the two playing bartenders at the
infamous new york city hotspot in 2000
sophomore sex comedy road trip he landed
the lead role of josh parker a man
forced to travel across the country in
order to stop a sex tape he made with
another girl from being delivered to his
long distance girlfriend
the following year meyer played lawyer
nick schaefer in the 2001 comedy rat
race where he competes in a race across
the desert funded by john cleese's
character donald sinclair on the small
screen meyer played jared franklin one
half of the title duo on franklin and
bash jared an unorthodox lawyer works
alongside his partner and longtime
friend peter bash played by mark paul
gossler meyer also joined the craft
co-star robin tunney in the 2019 legal
drama the fix playing the la district
attorney charlie wiest
laura lizzie played by christine taylor
is kind of the worst she's openly and
unapologetically racist to rochelle
taunting the young woman and deriding
her hair from yelling shark in the
middle of rochelle's dive to just
all-around nastiness lara's eventual
comeuppance is satisfying if not a bit
guilt-inducing outside of her role in
the craft we assume christine taylor is
perfectly nice why else would ben
stiller have married her in 2000 taylor
and stiller would go on to appear in
2001 zoolander and 2004's dodgeball a
true underdog story in zoolander viewers
will recognize taylor as the fictional
time magazine journalist matilda
jeffries whose hit piece makes the title
character derrick zoolander look like a
fool in dodgeball she portrays bank
lawyer kate veach where she dodges both
balls and unwanted advances from
stiller's character white goodman taylor
has a cameo in the 2008 action flick
satire tropic thunder appearing in the
film within the film simple jack
beginning in 2016 she took on the
recurring role of gail in hbo's series
search party she plays the rich boss to
alias shawcat's character dory
spanish actress assumed serena took on
the role of lyrio for the craft viewers
first meet lyrio when nancy and the gang
take sarah to her bookstore and proceed
to shoplift from it sarah surprises the
spiritually inclined shopkeeper by
actually paying for something the bulk
of serena's filmography has come an
international fare though she has logged
plenty of english language projects in
the years since the craft premiered
among those is the 2003 tv movie henry
viii she later appeared in the 2008
indie crime drama uncertainty starring
joseph gordon-levitt as the protagonist
bobby cerna appears as sylvia montero
mother to bobby's pregnant girlfriend
kate played by lynn collins
actor cliff de young plays sarah's
father in the craft while sarah has a
complicated relationship with her father
she's relieved to discover he's still
alive despite what bonnie nancy and
rochelle lead her to believe
in the movie's final scene sarah's
father can be seen packing up the car
while sarah confronts nancy and bonnie
the year after the craft was released de
young appeared in 1997's crime thriller
suicide kings deyoung plays marty the
lawyer to former mafia boss charlie
barrett portrayed by christopher walken
when charlie is kidnapped by a group of
well-meaning students in need of ransom
money marty looks into his employer's
disappearance
deyoung has racked up an impressive
who's who list of primetime tv drama
appearances as well he plays a lawyer on
the practice a reporter on the ncis
precursor jag a doctor on melrose place
and john ramsey in the tv movie getting
away with murder the jonbenet ramsay
mystery other highlights include a
four-episode stint as agent john bonicek
on the young and the restless and a
two-episode arc on grey's anatomy de
young's most recent credit came as joe
logo in the mockumentary reality queen
the show follows london logo joe's
daughter portrayed by julia faye west
who's determined to prove she's more
than just a vapid celebrity debutante
and heiress
nancy's mother grace downes is brought
to life by actor helen shaver she may
have lousy taste in men but she still
seems to luck out when it comes to their
deaths despite the uncanny circumstances
surrounding her late husband's passing
grace is too busy living the good life
to worry about things like mysterious
life insurance policies
shortly after the craft hit theaters
shaver appeared in the direct to video
sequel tremors 2 aftershocks she took on
the role of dr kate riley a geologist
whose field work brings her in close
proximity to the graboids a species of
subterranean creatures that's
terrorizing a mexican oil field
after original tremors character fred
ward portrayed by earl bassett saves dr
riley's life she becomes his love
interest
that same year shaver landed a main cast
role in poltergeist the legacy playing
dr rachel corrigan for four seasons of
the horror series rachel a skilled
psychiatrist is invited to join the
titular secret occult society after
receiving their aid though her cynicism
keeps her from believing in the
paranormal shaver also appeared in the
2007 indie drama numb she plays audrey
the mother to depressed screenwriter
hudson milbank portrayed by matthew
perry whose spiral of detachment leads
him to seek psychiatric help
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]